non
sur les territoires de qq et un
palestinien de gaza attaque un car de
touristes français blesse neuf personnes
ils voulaient venger les sept
palestiniens assassinés
hier près de tel aviv
il y en eut liège tout le candidat du
front de salut national littéralement
plébiscité en vertu des sondages malgré
les irrégularités souligné par
l'opposition les élections ou mais ne
seront pas contesté
l'immigration de nouveau à l'ordre du
jour demain à l'assemblée nationale
entre propositions et menaces
l'opposition entend vendre chèrement sa
participation à la table ronde de la fin
du mois lors des délibérations pour le
jury de la palme d'or 90 à cannes
ceux qui ont du nez paris sur le cyrano
de bergerac de jean-paul rappeneau
merveilleusement servi par gérard
depardieu
bonsoir les deux jours qui viennent de
s'écouler en israël et dans les
territoires occupés sont sûrement les
plus violents depuis le début il ya
trois mois
les soulèvements palestiniens et de la
guerre des pierres le massacre dimanche
de sept palestiniens par un jeune
israélien a été présenté officiellement
aujourd'hui comme un geste de folie
le geste d'un déséquilibré il n'en reste
pas moins que ce geste a provoqué une
explosion de violence dans les
territoires occupés ce matin ammann un
jeune palestinien a tiré sur des
touristes français faisant 10 blessés
dont quatre sont toujours hospitalisés
hervé dino l'attaqué a eu lieu alors que
les touristes français descendus de ce
quart pour visiter l'amphithéâtre romain
da manha l'agresseur a immédiatement
tiré sur les premiers membres du groupe
puis il est monté dans le bus vie dans
le chargeur de son pistolet à grenaille
et blessant un passager d'un coup de
couteau avant d'être immobilisée par la
police voulait rentrer dans le coeur
j'ai vu qu'ils se battent au début du
quart je suis parti j'ai vu du sang
partout
je les ai vus après sortir avec les
policiers les blessés neuf français un
photographe jordaniens ont été
transportés et la cité médicale el
bachir ce soir quatre d'entre eux sont
toujours hospitalisés
bien que choqué leur état de santé n'est
pas jugé inquiétant
l'ol paie et la jordanie par la voix du
roi hussein qui s'est rendu au chevet
des victimes ont condamné cet acte
criminel
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
l'auteur de l'attentât à mme hadja sirbé
douanes un palestinien originaire
d'hébron aurait voulu venger l'un de ses
proches tués hier dans l'attentât
perpétré dans la banlieue de tel-aviv
un attentat au cours duquel huit
palestiniens avaient perdu la vie et
justement depuis l'attentât de dimanche
la situation est devenue très critique
en cisjordanie et à gaza les
affrontements d'une violence extrême
entre palestiniens et soldats israéliens
ont fait sept morts et plusieurs
centaines de blessés depuis 10 heures
sylvie levey mais les stars de rôle
international communities un chef de
l'olp est consterné à la mesure de tout
l'engrenage de l'horreur qui sévissent
ce soir encore dans les territoires
occupés trois nouveaux tués ce jour et
94 blessés qui vient s'ajouter à la
liste des sept palestiniens a battu la
veille par les balles israéliennes des
affrontements qui avaient déjà blessé
700 personnes la poudrière où tout s'est
enflammé les camps de réfugiés de la
bande de gaza où vivent et les victimes
du massacre de dimanche matin alors à la
knesset ont fait les comptes on essaie
de comprendre pourquoi tout en calmant
le jeu en marge de la fel au secours que
vient de lancer yasser arafat ou nations
unies une déclaration d'isaac shamir
affichant son regret profond tout en
promettant un retour au calme au plus
vite
mais à quel prix cette explosion de
violence et bien sûr révélatrice du
climat très invités de la société
israélienne dans son ensemble crise
gouvernementale répéter affrontements
parfois violents entre les partisans de
la paix et les extrémistes qu'ils ne
veulent pas entendre parler d'eux
à log avec les palestiniens l'état
d'israël va devoir faire face à un débat
qui ressemble de plus en plus un conflit
ouvert
hélène risacher la catastrophe at elle
déjà commencé le jeune israélien qui a
assassiné hier huit palestiniens et
provoqué une explosion de violence dans
les territoires occupés est qualifié de
fou mais après cela comment organiser le
dialogue vers la paix le gouvernement
israélien se laisse emprisonné dans une
loi électorale qui empêche toute
majorité
résultat il se débat depuis un an et
demi dans la crise le premier ministre
itzhak shamir leader des conservateurs
du likoud se fait débordé sur sa droite
le coup de force d'ariel sharon en
février dernier montre que le front du
refus
ceux pour qui il n'est pas question de
discuter avec l'ol paie ce front du
refus est puissant parallèle à lui les
extrémistes orthodoxes reprennent des
slogans ouvertement anti palestinien et
anti arabes
en face les associations comme la paix
maintenant multiplient les
manifestations pour le dialogue mais les
sondages sont contradictoires
70 % des israéliens sont pour la paix
mais seulement 30 % sont favorables à la
création d'un état palestinien
or c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit sur
le terrain dans les territoires occupés
la tension ne baisse jamais encore plus
depuis le début de l'intifada il ya
trois ans l'armée israélienne est
devenue le symbole de l'occupation et
ses soldats les hommes de la sale
besogne qui tire aussi sur les enfants
on parle beaucoup de suicides chez les
jeunes appelés qui ne supportent plus ce
qu'ils ont à faire
mais les affrontements palestiniens et
forces de l'ordre continuent et dans ces
territoires aussi les intégristes
religieux font recette
ceux qui prônent le rejet des juifs à la
mer
dès lors malgré les récentes prises de
position modérée de l'ol fait de yasser
arafat
malgré les appels au dialogue du monde
entier aucune solution politique n'a été
trouvée en israël aucune discussion pour
la paix n'est même amorcé en roumanie
les premières élections libres et
démocratiques depuis 50 ans en fait
confirmé ce que vous occupez le pouvoir
depuis des années d'après les premiers
sondages il ya libye est secouée le
front de salut national sont plébiscités
par une très large majorité de romain
après une journée et une nuit de scrutin
parfois très agitée les bureaux de vote
sont restés ouverts jusqu'à 3 heures du
matin
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
bucarest jérôme cathala et marque doux
minuit première estimation il y ait ce
coup camper à nouer ratio est obtenu
respectivement 83 11 et 6 % des voix
quelques minutes plus tard sur la place
de l'université
quelques étudiants démontre une nouvelle
fois leur rapidité de réaction et sur un
badge improvisé un nouveau slogan 83% de
viscose 11% de coton 6% de nylon le
message est clair les trois ex candidats
sont mis dans le même sac et les
manifestants veulent continuer à
résister mais pour chanter l'hymne des
opposants le choeur manque un peu le
coup a été rude
elle veut pas d'elle je suivais milices
la résistance reste et je pense que mon
possible votre évolution
partagé entre pessimisme et incrédulité
et fatigue les manifestants déserteront
peu à peu la place de l'université mais
à quelques mètres de là plus un bruit
les permanences électorales sont bouclés
même si à l'intérieur quelques fidèles
attendent les premiers résultats
officiels
il faut dire qu'ici au parti libéral les
sondages ont quelque peu refroidi les
enthousiasmes
pas de grande fête non plus au siège du
front de salut national pourtant grand
vainqueur de ces élections
en fait la seule activité nocturne du
pays est concentrée à l'intérieur des
bureaux de vote
impensable il ya encore chaque mois on
nous a laissé entrer dans un bureau
filmer le dépouillement le vote ne s'est
terminée qu'une heure auparavant après
c'est important pour nous c'est que nous
avons voté et leur leader pour la
première fois et bien sûr la chiffre
aussi parce que dans une démocratie il
ya des sorties des bulletins et
comptabilisation des vous à comprendre
toute la nuit et pendant que se décide
ici le sort de la roumanie bucarest tort
après 50 ans de dictatures inutile de
dire que les premières élections libres
se sont déroulées sous haute
surveillance des observateurs étrangers
ont contrôlé la bonne marche des
élections dans l'ensemble il n'y a pas
eu d'irrégularités pourtant certains
observateurs restent très sceptiques
c'est le cas d'un parlementaire français
dans toutes les entreprises de bucarest
un mode horde rendez vous place de
l'université ceux qui craignent le
retour du communisme ceux qui ne veulent
pas oublier les morts de la révolution
bref ceux qui occupent la place depuis
des semaines cela sont revenus ils
dénoncent les irrégularités du scrutin
surtout en dehors des grandes villes
et il refuse le résultat des élections
appuyée par certains observateurs
notamment des français n'y a pas de
doute que dans un pays démocratique le
scrutin serait annulée d'ailleurs il
aurait sans doute pas pu se passer dans
les conditions de ce genre bien sûr tous
les observateurs étrangers n'ont pas
exprimé un avis aussi tranché
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on n'a pas
fini de parler du triple scrutin lierre
ici et d'en mesurer ses conséquences le
grand vainqueur de ces élections c'est
donc qu'il n'y ait ce coup d'après les
premiers résultats officiels il
obtiendrait près de 90% des voix aux
présidentielles son mouvement le front
de salut national est crédité lui de 70%
législatives et sénatoriales des
résultats qui installe confortablement
le nouveau numéro un roumain peut-être
trop confortablement
mémona hintermann vous êtes en direct de
bucarest qui on peut dire que ce soit
une liane des scores qui dérange
oui aujourd'hui manifestement le pouvoir
paraît très encombré par une victoire
qu'il trouve lui-même un peu trop
voyante 80% évidemment ça rappelle les
scores de chercher ce coup et cela
accrédite aussi les accusations de
manipulation des esprits au moins avant
le scrutin et tout à l'heure si liu
boucane l'idéologue du front et le
conseiller de yodelice coup me disait au
téléphone le président a accueilli les
premiers résultats avec un enthousiasme
modéré
nous espérons que les résultats
définitifs sur les présidentielles se
situeront plus près de 60% que de 80 pas
plus en tout cas ce véritable pépite les
visites si les chiffres se confirment
ont surpris les hommes du pouvoir eux
mêmes et il faudra maintenant qu'ils
s'organisent pour donner une nouvelle
constitution au pays
dans vingt jours un nouvel nouveau
gouvernement sera formé avec
probablement pétré romane le premier
ministre à sa tête et le pouvoir ne
désespère pas séduire un peu
l'opposition pour faire une sorte
d'ouverture à la roumaine
tout le monde est d'accord tout cas sur
une chose c'est que la roumanie
on nous avons apparemment un petit
problème de faisceau avec bucarest si
cela est possible nous retournerons à
bucarest au cours de ce journal pour
l'analyste politique du scrutin en
roumanie à mémona vous êtes à nouveau à
l'antenne nous l'avons été occupé
quelques instants je lui propose de
reprendre votre analyse
je reprends tout j'espère je voulais
dire que manifestement aujourd'hui le
pouvoir paraissait très encombré par
cette victoire qu'il trouve un peu trop
voyante lui même parce que 80 % des voix
cela rappelle les scores ceausescu et
cela accrédite évidemment les
accusations de manipulation des esprits
à tout cas avant le scrutin et tout à
l'heure si le cube rukh khan l'idéologue
du front et le conseiller de young les
secoue le président me disais par
téléphone le président accueilli avec un
enthousiasme modéré les premières
estimations
et il aimerait bien que les chiffres
définitifs se situe aux alentours de 60%
si ce plébiscite se confirme cela
signifie également que le fonds est
surpris lui-même par les chiffres
il faudra maintenant qu'ils se
réunissent pour donner notre
constitution au pays
dans vingt jours plus tard nouveau
gouvernement sera formé avec
probablement sa tête toujours le même
premier ministre péterait romane et le
pouvoir ne désespère pas séduit et les
hommes de l'opposition pour faire ce
qu'il appelle lui-même une sorte
d'ouverture à la roumaine tout le monde
est d'accord sur une chose c'est que ce
pays n'est pas prêt du tout de se
stabiliser
j'espère que m'avait entendu cette fois
c'était assez merci le la nature cette
analyse décidément très complète
en france l'actualité est marquée par
deux faits divers à grasse une explosion
dans une parfumerie industriel a fait un
mort et deux blessés légers des travaux
de soudure sur une cuve sont apparemment
à l'origine du sinistre d'importants
moyens de secours ont été aussitôt
envoyé sur place ils tentent toujours
en ce moment même de colmater une fuite
provoquée par l'explosion
c'est le deuxième accident de la sorte
en moins d'un mois et demi dans
l'entreprise près de reims une enquête
ce vient d'être ouverte cet après-midi
après l incendie la nuit dernière d'une
maison six personnes de la même famille
dont quatre enfants sont mortes
asphyxiées sans que personne n'ait pu
intervenir un court-circuit accidentelle
serait à l'origine du drame
anne moreau depuis deux ans la famille
leroy habiter ici dans ce pavillon neuf
d'un petit lotissement de loivre cette
nuit gaggini sophie jullien et
alexandrie ont trouvé la mort
ils avaient entre 3 et 8 ans mort
également leurs parents un drame auquel
les voisins ont assisté impuissants et
que le feu s'est déclaré vers une heure
du matin là d'entre eux pompier
volontaire a aussitôt donné l'alerté
en attendant les secours certains osant
bourinet laporte crier sans résultat à
l'intérieur de la maison aucun signe de
vie mardi je frappe et j'ai cronje j'ai
pas les hurlements partout bonsaï l'asm
monter trois marches on n'a pas pu les
pompiers ont découvert les corps des
quatre enfants au premier étage leurs
parents dont la chambre était situé au
rez-de-chaussée était près d'eux ils
sont morts asphyxiés sans avoir eu le
temps ni la force de les sauver en
politique ouverture demain à l'assemblée
nationale du débat sur l'immigration il
servira entre autres de galop d'essai à
la table ronde de matignon le 29 mai
prochain
l'opposition multiplient si les
initiatives avec de nouvelles
propositions aujourd'hui pour ne pas
laisser le terrain aux fonds national
daniel sportiello l'opposition qui veut
que le gouvernement s'engage de façon
claire sur sa politique de l'immigration
fait monter les enchères
à la veille du débat à l'assemblée
nationale ce matin c'est le rpr qui
réclamait dans une proposition de loi
les garanties supplémentaires sur
l'entrée et le séjour des étrangers en
s'appuyant sur la loi pasqua qu'il veut
rétablir en matière d'immigration
clandestine le parti de jacques chirac
réclame des peines a cru et pour
faciliter l'intégration des immigrés en
situation régulière cette fois ils
demandent à l'état d'aider
financièrement les communes
en difficulté en matière d'immigration
valéry giscard d'estaing n'est pas en
reste
dans une lettre adressée au premier
ministre il demande d'inscription de
quatre principes dans la charte minimale
proposé par matignon les voici
la france n'a plus vocation à être pays
d'immigration
les résidents étrangers en droit au
respect de leur personne les étrangers
en situation régulière seront protégés
les autres expulsé face à ces
surenchères jusqu'à quel point michel
rocard pour at il donné des gages
difficile pour le premier ministre de
préserver coûte que coûte le fragile
consensus amorcée lors du défilé commun
dans les rues de paris sans irriter ceux
qui à gauche ne sont pas prêts à payer
au prix fort le ticket d'entrée à la
table ronde de matignon politique
toujours jean marie le pen ne tiendra
pas la réunion du groupe des droites
européennes à la trinité-sur-mer le 5
juin prochain
la municipalité vient en effet de le lui
interdire la décision a été votée ce
matin par la majorité des 15 conseillers
municipaux réunis à huis clos depuis la
profanation de carpentras plusieurs
villes en france sont ainsi mis le front
national en quarantaine en refusant de
lui louer des salles thorel philippe
poiraud union des parlementaires
d'extrême droite n'aura pas lieu dans la
salle des fêtes de la mairie de la
trinité sur mer
ainsi en a décidé ce matin le conseil
municipal après deux heures de réunion à
huit clos
finalement le maire monsieur migraine a
décidé de se rallier à la décision de
ses trois adjoints et de plusieurs
conseillers municipaux les trois
adjoints étaient prêtes à donner leur
démission dans le cas où le maire
accepte de louer ses locaux aux
parlementaires européens
les conseillers municipaux se sont
prononcés par la négative
il leur est apparu en effet que la
révoltante profanation de carpentras
intervenu entre temps et la présence
d'un député allemand contesté avait créé
un choc émotionnel dont les conséquences
seraient susceptibles de troubler
l'esprit des trinitaires
la mérite de la trinité contestez vous
l'avez compris notamment la venue de
franz schubert représentants de
l'extrême droite ouest allemand et un
sirh de fichiers nas s tout de suite les
autres faits marquants de l'actualité en
france
claire sébastien nouvel épisode pour les
squatteurs de la place de la réunion
dans le 20ème arrondissement la mairie
de paris propose des relogements en
banlieue dans des hlm lui appartenant la
municipalité communiste de saint denis a
déjà fait savoir qu'elle refusait cette
solution qui selon elle renforce les
ghettos les perturbations du tgv
s'intensifie dans trois départements de
savoie le mouvement dure depuis six
jours à l'appel des cheminots cgt cfdt
qui protestent contre les nouvelles
dispositions du parc ont cncf qui selon
eux prolonge le temps de travail des
conducteurs
du nouveau dans la sphère des bagagistes
de l'aéroport de nice où un véritable
gang opérait depuis plusieurs années ce
soir sur les 25 personnes gardées à vue
très ont été présentés au parquet et
simon notre défense était délivrée par
le juge pour vol avec effraction et
rossel fausse note alors qu'istres de
lyon où les musiciens maintiennent leur
désaveu à leur chef et directeur musical
emmanuel krivine motive son mauvais
caractère
le maire de lyon soutien le chef
d'orchestre tandis que le syndicat
national des artistes musiciens qui a
voté un préavis de grève illimité
menacent d'étendre la grève à tous les
orchestres de france
des pesticides pourrait être à l'origine
de la pollution de la cei une rivière
très poissonneuses de moselle depuis
samedi des milliers de poissons sont
morts sur les 50 km du parcours de cette
rivière grâce aux barrages réalisé en
aval la pollution semble à présent
stabiliser des nouvelles des étoiles
avec deux motifs de satisfaction
première bonne nouvelle
obl fonctionne neuvièmement le télescope
géant envoyé une première photographie
des étoiles plus belle et plus précise
encore que ce que les spécialistes
avaient escompté
véronique gaurel un amas d'étoilés
éloigner cette karina c'est son nom est
situé à 1260 années lumière de la terre
c'est la première photographie de
l'espace enregistré par le télescope
spatial hubble
hier il a fallu deux heures pour
transmettre les clichés à la terre et
une petite heure de plus pour
transformer les données électroniques à
une image belle ne se contente plus de
voir les étoiles
il n'en ai fait voir il était temps
depuis sa mise sur orbite le 25 avril
dernier
le télescope spatial a connu une série
de problèmes techniques au point qui
aura fallu quinze jours lui des 8 prévus
pour recevoir la première image les
responsables de la mission sont soulagés
d'abord parce que les clichés atteste du
bon fonctionnement du télescope
ensuite parce qu'ils ont permis de
découvrir après un solide traitement
informatique une double étoiles jusqu
alors invisible de la terre un
encouragement pour la nasa qui espère
obtenir dans les semaines à venir des
clichés cette fois plus précis ce que
l'on attend bien entendu c'est août
découvrir des systèmes planétaires c'est
évidemment découvrir des astres
extrêmement lointain adéquat zde coizard
ou des galaxies qui vont peut-être ou
même sûrement nous renseigner sur la
façon dont l'univers s'est formé parce
que comme vous le savez regarder loin
c'est en fait remonter le passé nous ne
faisons que nous avons une caméra à
remonter le temps ne pouvons pas voir le
présent de l'univers et à partir de là
on espère qualifier ou ne pas qualifier
les différentes théories qui essaye
d'expliquer ce qui s'est passé il ya 15
milliards d'années en particulier la
fameuse théorie du big bang
le festival de cannes avec le début du
palmarès de ce 43e festival est une très
bonne nouvelle jarre depardieu a reçu la
palme
meilleur interprète masculin pour cyrano
de bergerac de jean-paul rappeneau le
prix d'interprétation féminine a été
décerné à krystyna janda pour un film
polonais l'interrogatoire et au dernier
soir du festival premier bilan du cinéma
le marché du septième art tourner de
mesure de mieux en mieux c'est peut-être
le signe d'un meilleur état de santé de
la machine du cinéma jean françois
grégoire et christophe airaud nous font
un diagnostic de cinéphiles il aura
fallu qu alain delon nous fasse son
numéro pendant la montée des marches
pour vivre enfin un grand moment
c'était le 18 mai et le festival était
quand même commencé depuis huit jours
samedi pour cyrano gérard depardieu lui
a plutôt fait dans le soft
seul avant de nom sylvester stallone
avait réussi à en fibres et la croisette
en dévastant son passage la moitié de la
terrasse du carlton
à part ça pas grand chose il n'y a plus
beaucoup de folie à cannes et pourtant
le festival ça use ça use surtout ceux
qui travaillent pour les grandes maisons
de production américaines de préférence
plus que jamais on a vendu cette année
des centaines de films dont certains pas
encore terminée affiche déjà de
prometteuses distribution plus ça va et
plus la durée du festival raccourcis
aussi en flammes moins qu'autrefois et
les marins américains du porte-avions
eisenhower ont dû être un pays insulaire
puis encore un souvenir des vétérans qui
ont tous deux eu l'âge d'or du festival
quand la piste assez que la palme d'or
vient tout juste d'être décerné à david
lynch pour son film wild
ateras en sport à sept jours des
internationaux de france de tennis la
classe la chasse aux billets a battu son
plein aujourd'hui c'était le dernier
jour
reportage serge y en l'avenir et tout
gens qui se lèvent tous les passionnés
de tennis l'ont compris les candidats
aux dernières places pour la quinzaine
se sont levés bien avant le soleil pour
patienter jusqu'à l'ouverture des
guichets prévu à 10h30 patience
obligatoire quand on n'est pas prêt
voyant j'ai raté le coche voilà alors
c'est pour ça que je me retrouve là sans
quoi l'année dernière j'avais tout
réservé par par écrit avec un chèque et
tous et cette année j'ai pas pu espère
trouver des quarts de finale où denis ci
n'a pas de coûts annexes non pas s'il
reste que mes courts annexes
ce sera bien difficile le central ne
contient que seize mille cinq cents
places et la demande est deux à trois
fois supérieure à l'offre pour certains
jours
mais attention le match n'est pas perdu
il reste environ 10 % des places qui
sont essentiellement des places courts
annexes et sur le court central il reste
3000 places qui sont répartis entre le
premier jour le lundi 28 mai et le jeudi
16 juin en deuxième semaine
bonne surprise rue gordon bennett le
petit déjeuner est servi gracieusement
nous sommes présents depuis 5 heures du
matin pour venir soutenir tous ces
fanatiques de tennis qui sont là pour
acheter leurs billets nous leur offrons
un café et un croissant le journal
tennis de france tous offert par ta
niche de france à un an de fêter son
centenaire
roland garros un succès croissant voilà
fin de cette édition le prochain rendez
vous avec l'information c'est à 22h40
foire 3 présenté par marc hautement tout
de suite la météo complète de florence
la bonsoir
là